we've got three bananas here one two
three so I'm starting with three bananas
and I want to add some number of bananas
so that I end up with ten bananas so
this is what I'm starting with I'm
starting with three and I want to end up
with ten one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten so what do I have
to add to the three to get to ten and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try this out on your own so let's work
through this so let's just start adding
bananas so that's three so now let me
add a fourth that would be my fourth
banana five bananas six bananas seven
bananas eight bananas nine bananas and
ten bananas so how many bananas did I
add so now I added some number of
bananas here so in total I have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
so how many did I have to add to the
three in order to get to that the total
of ten in order to get this 10 right
over here well we could just count these
this is one this is two this is three
four five six seven
I added seven bananas I added seven
bananas to the original three bananas to
get to 10 so three plus seven is equal
to 10 and you can see that what we have
on this left side is indeed equal to
what we have on the right side on the
left side we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
bananas and on the right hand side we
have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so they are
indeed equal